so we have a piecewise linear function
right over here for different intervals
of x g of x is defined by
a a line although the line changes
depending what interval of x we are
actually in and so let's think about its
domain and then we'll think about its
range so the domain of this just as a
review the domain is the set of all
inputs for which this function is
defined and our input variable here is x
so it's a set of all x values for which
this function is defined and we see here
anything anything negative six or lower
our function isn't defined if x is
negative six or or lower than that i
don't it doesn't it doesn't fall into
one of these three intervals so there is
no definition for it it doesn't say hey
do this in all other cases for x it's
just saying look if x falls into one of
these three conditions apply this and if
x doesn't fall into one of those three
conditions well this function g is just
not defined
so to fall into one of these three you
have to be at least greater than
negative 6. so this part right over here
the low end of our domain is defined
right over there so we we could say
negative 6
negative 6 is less than x and i'm
leaving so actually let me just write it
here all
real numbers actually let me write it
this way
x i could write it more mathy i could
say x is a member of the real numbers
such that
such that negative 6
is less than x
negative 6 is less than x and let's
think about the upper bound so as x goes
and i just want to make sure that we
fill in all the gaps between x being
greater than negative 6 and x is less
than or equal to 6. so let's see as we
go up 2 and including negative 3 we're
in this clause as soon as we cross
negative 3 we fall into this clause up
to 4 but as soon as we get to 4 we're in
this clause
up to and including 6
so x
at the high end is just to be less than
or equal to 6
less than or equal to 6.
now another way to say this in kind of
less mathy notation is
x
can
be
any
real number
any real number
such that
such
that
negative 6 is less than x is less than
or equal to 6. these two statements are
equivalent so now let's think about the
range of this function
let's think about the range and the
range this is the set of all inputs or
sorry this is the set of all outputs
that this function can take on or all of
the values that this function can take
on
and to do that let's just think about as
x goes but is x varies or as x can be
any of the values in this interval what
are what are the different values that g
of x could take on so let's think about
that g of x
is going to be between what and what g
of x is going to be between what and
what
g of x
is going to be between what and what and
it might actually this might be some
equal signs there but i'm going to worry
about that in a second
so when does this thing hit its low
point so this thing hits hits its low
point when x is as small as possible
and x is going to be as small as
possible when it's approaching negative
6.
so if x were equal to negative 6 it
can't equal negative 6 here but if x is
equal to negative 6 then this thing over
here would be equal to negative 6 plus 7
would be
would be 1. so if x is greater than
negative 6 g of x is going to be greater
than 1. or another way of thinking about
it if negative 6 is less than x
then 1 is going to be less than g of x
and the whole reason i said that if you
just put negative 6 into this negative 6
plus 7 is equal to 1.
now this thing's going to hit a high end
when it's as large as possible and the
largest value in this interval that we
can take on is x being equal to negative
3. so when x is equal to negative 3
negative 3 plus 7
is equal to
4 positive 4 and it can actually take on
that value because this is less than or
equal to so we can actually take on x
equals negative 3 in which case g of x
actually will take on positive 4. so
let's do that for each of these
now here we have 1 minus x so this is
going to take on its smallest value when
x is as large as possible so the largest
value x can approach 4 it can't quite
take on 4 but it's going to approach 4.
so if x let's see if we said x was 4
although that's not this clause here 1
minus x 1 minus 4 is negative 3.
so as long as x is less than 4
then negative 3 is going to be less than
g of x i want to make sure that makes
sense to you because it's a little bit
confusing because
this takes on its minimum value when x
is approaching
or it's it's approaching its minimum
value when x is approaching it's when x
is approaching its maximum value because
we're subtracting it so if you take the
upper end even though this doesn't
actually include 4 but as we approach 4
we can say okay 1 minus 4 is negative 3.
so that's so g of x is always going to
be greater than that it's always going
to be less than well what happens as we
approach x being equal to negative 3.
so 1 minus negative 3 is going to be
positive 4.
so this is going to be positive 4 right
over here and these are both less than
not less than or equal to because these
are both less than right over here
and now let's think about this right
over here so 2x minus 11 it's going to
hit its maximum value when x is as large
as possible so its maximum value is
going to be hit when x is equal to 6. so
2 times 6 is 12 minus 11 well that's
going to be 1. so it's maximum value is
going to be 1 it's actually going to be
able to hit it because x can be equal to
6.
and its minimum value is going to be
when x is equal to 4 and it actually can
be equal to 4. we have this less than or
equal sign right over there
so 2 times 4 is 8 minus 11 is negative
3.
so g of x in this case can get as low as
negative 3 when x is equal to 4.
so now let's think about all of all of
the values that g of x can take on so we
could say we could write this a bunch of
ways we could write
g of x
is going to be a member of the real
numbers
such that let's see what's the lowest
value g of x can take on g of x can can
get as low as
negative three it can even be equal to
negative three this one just has it
being greater than negative three but
here can be greater than or equal to
negative three
so negative three is less than or equal
to g of x and it can get as high as
it can get as high as let's see it's
defined all the way to one and then or i
shouldn't say it's defined all the way
can take on values up to one but it can
also take on values beyond one it can
take on values all the way up to
including four over here
so it can take on values up two and
including four so g of x is a member of
real numbers such that negative three is
less than or equal to g of x is less
than or equal to 4. so the set of all
values that g of x can take on between
inclu and including negative 3 and
positive 4.